dans cette crise sanitaire les services
de secours sont bien sûr très engagées
notamment les pompiers des yvelines qui
ont depuis le 1er mai un nouveau
directeur le colonel stéphane milot qui
est avec nous m'ont soir directeur
départemental des services d'incendié de
secours et et chef de corps des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines racontez-nous déjà
votre prise de fonction qui forcément a
dû être un peu particulière dans le sont
aussi dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire
effectivement le le contexte est un peu
particulier néanmoins les symboles de
l'installation du nouveau chef de corps
ont été bons étaient respectées les
autorités ce soit le préfet le président
du conseil d'administration du 10 où le
président du conseil départemental m'ont
accueilli et nous avons dès le 4 mai
procédé très symboliquement et à huis
clos à une levée des couleurs et un
dépôt de gerbe en l'honneur de
l'ensemble des sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines décédé en service commandé
alors vous avez exercé dans le
département de l'essonne et des yvelines
on va y revenir juste dans un instant
mais aussi dans l'aveyron et en
seine-et-marne où vous avez été pendant
cinq ans le directeur adjoint du sdiss
un service départemental d'incendié et
de secours
comment vous aborder cette nouvelle
mission dans quel état d'esprit
l'abordez-vous d'abord une immense joie
un état d'esprit très positif malgré
évidemment le contexte
et puis c'est pour moi un vrai challenge
de revenir sur un territoire attractif
où j'ai passé quasiment déjà 10 ans dans
de différentes affectations donc un état
d'esprit très positif et une énorme
envie de continuer à faire progresser le
dise je vais vous demander justement
s'il y avait un engouement particulier
pour voir venir sur ce territoire des
yvelines où vous avez déjà exercé comme
chef chef du centre de secours principal
de versailles chef d'état-major du sdiss
des yvelines également et est aussi chef
du groupement territorial ouest du
département est ce qu'il ya un
engouement particulier où il ya à
revenir sur ce territoire
oui oui bien sûr c'est un territoire
territoire illinois et les elvinois son
sont à la fois les gens très chaleureux
et puis le territoire est très attractif
de nombreux enjeux dans le domaine de la
sécurité civile
et des services d'incendié et de secours
donc effectivement mon affectation qui
est à une candidature donc un acte
délibéré de ma paraît effectivement
motivée par beaucoup d'affect même si
même si j'ai conscience de des
responsabilités qui aujourd'hui sur moi
tel objectif vous vous êtes fixé à la
tête du sdiss des yvelines à l'abord
continuer l'action telle qu'elle a été
engagé par par mes prédécesseurs sous
l'autorité d'alexandre joly le président
du conseil d'administration du sdiss
d'avoir une comptine une continuité
importante et puis une adaptation du
sdiss aux nouveaux enjeux et
s'inscrivent de kobe de nous montre un
certain nombre de nouveaux enjeux
auxquels le dise doit faire face on l'a
dit un arrivent et forcément dans ce
contexte particulier du coup on avec
virus de cette crise sanitaire
quel est l'engagement comment sont
engagés ces sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines dans cette crise on imagine
pleinement pleinement engagé dans cette
crise sanitaire
alors effectivement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le secours d'urgence à
personne représente près de 90% de
l'activité quotidienne des sapeurs
pompiers tout au long de l'année
cette crise des coville a évidemment
mobilisé les sapeurs-pompiers pleinement
avec nos moyens secouriste nos véhicules
de secours aux victimes mais aussi une
autre chaîne médicale avec nos
infirmiers et mon médecin sapeur pompier
dans la prise en charge des cas suspects
parce que parce que quand nous
intervenons nous ne savons pas
réellement si les gens ont commis ou
simplement des symptômes qui on
rassemble et nous avons dû prendre
l'ensemble des précautions nécessaires
pour protéger le personnel avec aussi
les autres interventions qui ne s'arrête
pas pour autant on l'a vu cette semaine
32 pompiers des yvelines qui sont
intervenus lors d'un incendie à
sartrouville il ya aussi le week end du
8 mai où beaucoup d'interventions sont
survenus ensuite aux intempéries il faut
tout de même continué malgré ces crises
sanitaires les autres interventions à
côté bien sûr le
même même pendant le profit demande
autres interventions
même si elles ont baissé étaient
présentes le spectre opérationnelle des
sapeurs pompiers qui est très large ce
soit évidemment le secours de chance à
personne mais aussi des accidents de la
route les incendies tout ça continue à
notre mission de secours dans lequel on
doit en permanence adapter et notre
organisation nous ont permis de résister
et d'être résilient à cette crise qui
même aujourd'hui encore même si
l'intensité a diminué nécessite un
certain manque de moyens d'aider sa part
confié l'organisation de vos services
justement est-ce qu'on peut la rappeler
combien de sapeurs-pompiers sont engagés
dans le département des yvelines alors
on sait qu'il est des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et aussi volontaire
combien de de force comptez-vous dans
les yvelines alors 78 ha je fais un
chiffre comme quatre mille 4000 agents
des sapeurs pompiers professionnels des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
et je n'oublie pas les personnels
administratifs qui nous permettent aussi
de fonctionner dans de nombreux domaines
voilà c'est 4000 agents au service du
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours qui avec un des effectifs de
garde toute la journée assure la
distribution des secours sur département
une dernière l'organisation vous voyez
une intégration
non mais je vous en prie allez-y allez-y
le service départemental d'incendié et
de secours est un établissement public
qui est placée sous le commandement
opérationnel du préfet mais qui est
financé par les collectivités locales
que sont le département et les communes
un dernier mot pour terminer sur cette
crise sanitaire avec aussi des pompiers
qui ont payé leur tribut dans cette
période début avril nous apprenions la
mort d'olivier lugan pompier volontaire
des yvelines décédé du coronavirus
l'épidémie n'a pas épargné les sapeurs
pompiers n'ont effectivement comme com
à l'instar de la population mais en plus
dans notre exposition au virus
nous avons eu un certain nombre de
sapeurs pompiers et hospitalisée notre
infirmiers olivet du gant qui est décédé
à lui contracté le virus dans son
activité libérale parce qu'il était
infirmier volontaire non pas l'ensemble
elle n'a pas contracté dans le cadre de
son activité de sapeur pompier néanmoins
toute la communauté des sapeurs pompiers
est très solidaire avec aujourd'hui
encore sa famille pour l'aider dans un
certain nombre de démarches et puis dans
cette période très particulière
évidemment merci colonel mulot d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous mais je
rappelle que vous voir le tout nouveau
directeur des services d'incendié et de
secours des yvelines